What's your name?
Adam.
Adam. Know Adam ain't no hero name.
You need something metal,
something cool, like
Molly Hatchet, Iron Maiden, Def Leppard,
something cool like that.
Think about it.
I like Adam.
Adam by itself sucks.
You know, you.
Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie
This will be my Guardians of the Galaxy
3 Alternate ending
deleted scene video Marvel just revealed
a completely different ending,
which changes a lot of the future
of Marvel's Avengers level crossovers.
In a lot of the space based movies,
as well as a bunch of cool deleted scenes
and details about high evolutionary
past visits to Earth, which they reveal
happened during the eighties.
We'll talk about that too.
suddenly, Nick Fury
is getting so much busier with all these
aliens visiting planet Earth
back in the eighties, in the nineties.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
and careful spoilers from the movie
if you haven't seen it yet,
because we need to talk about everything.
Mostly the ending, obviously.
I will stomp on their skulls.
Thank you so much.
That brains between my fingers.
I'm going to piss on that dead body
and make love to that carcasses.
Well, that's a bit much.
but in the theatrical version
of the movie.
At the end, Rockett
finally confronts high evolutionary
after spending years running from him,
avoiding him as much as possible.
He's meant to be about 15 years old
in the MCU in present day,
and it seems like based
on his level of development
when he escaped, he's been on the run
for at least ten years or more.
in with the help of the rest of the
guardians of the Galaxy, they all tag team
him almost kill him with rocket stopping
short of double tapping him with his gun
just to make sure that he's dead.
Gomorrah even rips his face off,
which they use in the movie
to make him a little more comic book
accurate.
because in the comics, high
evolutionary wears
a red mass that covers his entire head,
mostly
to hide the fact that years of experiments
and upgrades that he performed on himself
had totally messed his face up.
Like his face is messed up in the movie.
but in the comics, the big difference is
that he did that to himself in the movie.
Rockett did that, clawing his face off
when he escaped.
They also use that in the movie
to pay off all the face off references
from earlier in the film
because his face literally comes off.
so as he's lying there
barely alive and faceless, Rockett decides
not to kill him, both to show him mercy,
to show how much he's grown as a person,
even though he's technically a raccoon,
even though it takes
to the very end of the movie
before he realizes that he really is
a raccoon fun fact.
Two he's related to all those baby
raccoons that he actually saves.
those are part of the original raccoons,
that high
evolutionary selected rocket from end
they want to show that Rocket's
not the same bitter, spiteful raccoon
you meet in the first Guardians movie.
He's way more mature.
He started a process is trauma at high
evolutionary his hands
and also the whole idea
is that at this point in the movie
after he destroyed his own creation
counter earth his own actions
obsessing over Rocket Hill under the utter
destruction of his own ship,
the loss of his next level being the raise
that Falabella Quasar belong
to, that he just created
in all the other research and information
that he gained over hundreds of years.
He's meant to be about
300 years old in the MCU.
his actions led to the utter
loss of everything he previously owned
or created, basically.
So he was left with nothing,
not even his own base.
So killing him would have been a mercy.
So it's almost more hard core to leave him
alive.
Rocket does leave him alive.
And in the theatrical cut,
we see all the Guardians of the Galaxy
saving fire,
Lavelle's new race of children,
All the animals, high
evolutionary had kept four experiments,
taking them to nowhere to live.
we see high evolutionary is cube ship
completely destroyed.
It finishes blowing up and you never
actually see what happened to his body.
there was a lot of speculation about this
because it's a comic book movie.
You don't see his body.
It usually means he survives somehow.
and here's the thing.
Chuck Moody, Rugy himself, high
evolutionary himself, actually confirmed
this big alternate ending deleted scene.
In the alternate ending,
they filmed a much more obvious
looking scene of Drax carrying the high
evolutionary, barely alive
body off of his ship with everyone else,
the animals taking him to nowhere.
also there's the idea in
the theatrical cut that in the aftermath,
the rest of the ending of the movie
where Peter Quill names Rocket,
the new leader of the Guardians, announces
he's taking a break for a hot minute
till Avengers
Kane Dynasty at least goes back to Earth
in the rest of the Guardians.
I'll go their separate ways
in the alternate ending version of this
where they made it more obvious
that high evolutionary survived.
back on nowhere we see Rocket
put him in a prison even though it's
kind of like has two graphics
because they didn't
finish the previous like they got this far
long before they deleted the scene.
then they had the funny taxi
without a warlock
where it seems like he's working up
to calling himself the full name
Adam Warlock from the comics.
Remember it was Aisha that called him Adam
in high evolutionary called him Warlock.
So this was going to jam
those two names together. Basically.
when he originally started out
in the comics, he was just called Warlock.
He didn't get the Adam name
till he crossed over
with the high evolutionary in the Counter
Earth saga.
so it makes sense that they introduce him
during this storyline
with the high evolutionary la.
The way crackling is suggesting
that he named himself
after an eighties hair metal band.
something cool, like Molly Hatchet,
Iron Maiden, Def Leppard,
something cool like that.
Think about it.
I like Adam. Adam by itself sucks.
So the fact that high evolutionary
survived raises some questions
about his future in the MCU
because he's a huge character.
Chuck Moody Woogie was a fantastic villain
to his performance, probably
one of the best villain performances
in a marvel movie in a long, long time.
so, even if they'd actually perma
killed him, like even if it was confirmed
that he had died,
I still would have loved to see him
come back as a variant
in some future movie.
But since this MCU version
is technically still alive,
I'd love to see him
come back in a future space based movie.
Are bigger crossovers like bigger Avengers
level movies
with him adapting more of his high
evolutionary comic book stories?
because in the comics, he's
actually much more involved
in the big crossover events.
He winds up working with the heroes
just as much as he winds up
playing the villain in different stories.
in fact, a lot of those stories
James Gunn borrowed from
for the Plot of Guardians three,
particularly out of Warlocks, BackStory
like High Evolutionary,
actually helps him a lot in his backstory.
he's the person that upgraded Adam Warlock
and gave him the soul gem
he also worked
with the Guardians of the Galaxy
during the Annihilation
storyline against a nihilist.
And then later the sequel story
with the Return of Ultron.
I just did a big video too,
about in the Nihilist deleted scene
because he was actually going to be
a big character during the movie.
At one point,
it would have been a much bigger change
to the character
because obviously
analysis of Big Fantastic
Four characters all link that video
in the description below
because it's actually pretty cool.
this is Chuck Moody Boogie
talking about how evolutionary
his time on earth
during the eighties, specifically.
I visited your planet many years ago.
Earth hasn't been my planet
in a long time. If people had
wonderful spirit,
the arts and music and literature
with some of the finest in the universe,
so it sounds like for the movie, James
Dean created all this extra backstory
that he didn't wind up telling the actors
too much about during the day
just so they didn't overcrowd
whatever their scenes were in present day.
But is way more stuff that just didn't
make it into that theatrical cut.
you have to imagine how evolutionary
with his advanced technology
like he's already hundreds of years old
visiting Earth in the 1980s with Samuel L
Jackson still in his prime,
still a young man in shield calls
and has probably not quite yet
become an agent
because during the nineties
he was meant to be like a very green,
very brand new agent.
it even though I don't expect them
to address high evolutionary time on earth
during the Secret Invasion series,
I do think we'll learn more about Nick
Fury's history with Shield
during the eighties.
there was a lot going on in the MCU
during that period.
Mostly Howard Stark
still incredibly active
because he wasn't killed by Winter Soldier
till the nineties.
that was also before Janet Van
Dyne had been lost in the Quantum realm.
So Hank Pym and Janet
Van Dyne were still very active as Ant-Man
and the WASP working with Shield
and Peggy Carter, who was also still
very active at that point,
is a much older version of Peggy Carter.
remember all the flashback scenes
during the time heist in Avengers
Endgame at Camp
Lehigh were during the seventies,
high evolutionary on earth
would be even after that.
there was another deleted scene
that we learned about
with a very naked version of Gomorrah.
A lot of you asking, what was she doing?
Why was she naked in the scene?
this probably would have been
when they were changing out
of their prison suits
after they made it back to the Guardians
new ship the Bowie,
after they'd escaped the giant space
Butthole in it was probably part of Peter
Quill continuing to pine for her,
trying to win her back,
because at this point in the movie, he
still hadn't completely gotten over that.
It wasn't till the very end of the movie
when he was like,
okay, I'll see you when I see you.
We were a lot of fun, and they kind of
both went their separate ways.
Being friends.
in, it's not necessarily a deleted scene,
but it's a bit of the subtext
to the movie with James Gunn and Karen
Gillan Nebula talking about this.
So Karen Gillan in real life
actually said that she feels like Nebula
now has a crush on Peter Quill in the last
couple of years since Avengers Endgame.
But she has no idea how to process
it emotionally just because
she's been so shouty,
stabby, trying to get over her own trauma
the same way that rocket
was getting over his trauma with high
evolutionary nebula, just dealing with her
trauma and her back story within those.
it was that you were in love with.
It sounds more like her.
Her husband. Do not bring me.
Oh. Knock it off.
What ever knows how black your eyes were?
They were replaced by my father
as a method of torture. He.
He picked a pretty set.
so I think the whole idea is that
Nebula is just learning to open herself
to those kinds of emotions.
And we're not going to see her
get together with Peter Quill
or anything like that.
Like this is just Karen Gillan talking
with James Gunn and James Gunn being like,
You know what?
I hadn't completely intended that,
but I do kind of believe it.
so it's
more of the subtext of the character.
Like it's
not the actual text of the movie.
in this doesn't mean that Nebula
is going to get together with Peter Quill
or anything like that.
It just means
that she's kind of crushing on him
a little bit, whereas previously
she would have never even considered
that part of her stuff,
like it would have been buried
so deeply in her psyche
that it would never been a thing before.
there were a bunch of deleted scenes
that James Gunn's
been posting of Rocket in his friends
when he was a child.
Like Leila,
there's a child version of Rocket T floor,
just all scenes of them
figuring stuff out for the movie. end,
he did reveal that at least two deleted
scenes will wind up on the Blu ray.
But he didn't say which ones
he's going to put on the Blu ray
for the most part,
he said there weren't a ton
of deleted scenes from the movie,
like traditional deleted scenes, Yeah.
You know, you just got to change it
from yellow to purple.
you always this irritating?
Yes, I think.
I think so. They're my guys.
but it sounds like there were a couple
of really big ones, which I mostly list
here, like the Nihilist deleted scene
and my other video.
if they reveal any more deleted scenes,
of course I'll do videos for them.
We're in the middle of Marvel
secret invasion episodes.
I'm doing videos for everything.
Be sure to enable alerts for that.
My episode for video will post next week.
Click here for that and click here
for my Guardians of the Galaxy three
A nihilist deleted scene.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!